good morning hey wait what day is it oh
I could just look at my calendar it's
Friday August 26 thank you so much it's
question Friday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it you ever get
frustrated being a muggle how do you
know on the muggle favorite essay you
have ever read the crack up by f scott
Fitzgerald why hasn't my boyfriend
kissed me even though we've been going
for almost five months wait going going
we're certainly not to first base
anybody huh base jokes is that still a
thing listen up anonymous young Twitter
user you are a powerful young woman
kissing is not something that happens to
you it's something that happens with you
so talk to your boyfriend with whom you
have been going low these five months
and be honest with him how goes the
tiffy Oh signing this somewhat under
represents my progress I'm at about
35,000 although I am temporarily out of
read sharpies I have a long way to go
how many sharpies have you gone through
so far like about this many that's gonna
take a while to clean up is it too late
to preorder a signed copy
no all pre-orders of The Fault in Our
Stars will be signed in fact the whole
first printing is being signed which
means all the books that go out to
bookstores are being signed to I just
don't know how fast they're gonna sell
out so I can only like absolutely
guarantee that the pre-orders will be
signed but will you sign the ones from
Amazon UK yes does it have to be
pre-ordered from yeah no all pre-orders
will be signed
can we pre-order the book from somewhere
yes England yes Canada yes it doesn't
matter where you live or where you
preorder it or whether you are wearing
pants at the time of ordering all
pre-orders will be signed huh let's move
on what Hogwarts house would you be and
also what is the capital of Luxembourg
I'm kind of a raven puff and Luxembourg
Raven puff Luxembourg would be a great
Pottermore name what's your favorite
type of hat my people huntin hat how
much do you love kittens
I love kittens like
yes much I'm not a big kitten person
bacon or cake cake it just curious what
is your opinion of anime and main gay I
also love that you actually say main gay
right first thank you for noticing my
excellent pronunciation of main gay
second I love anime and main gay
describe your favorite paradox okay so
you want to walk through a doorway but
before you can walk through that doorway
you have to walk half way to the door
and before you can do that you have to
walk half way to the halfway point etc
basically you have to traverse infinity
to go anywhere I don't see how you ever
gonna get through the door that's called
Zeno's paradox is very important to me
do you have a tumblr do i fishing-boat
proceeds on board comm link in the
doobly-doo can you do question Tuesday
with peanut butter face briefly what
works of yours are you most proud of I'm
fairly proud of my career as a
professional person who puts peanut
butter on his face hi hi favorite
punctuation mark interrobang Elmo or
Grover right so every morning I wake up
with a song in my head and for years it
was always a wonderful song like by the
mountain goats or Hank green or
something but lately it's been the same
song every morning Elmo has two ducks
quack quack 2 Birds of uh Grover how do
you feel about Scotland's national
animal fight you mean the bagpipes I
love bagpipes what do mean it's not an
animal sure it's an animal with responds
to stimulus it can reproduce you can't
what are all those like holes and pointy
things for them googling Scotland's
national and unicorns hate them does
Sarah have any input into your writing
process have any of her ideas ever made
it into your stories yeah tons of stuff
from imagining the future as a kind of
nostalgia and Looking for Alaska to all
the pranks in Paper Towns and she
contributed hugely to The Fault in Our
Stars what was the original title of
Looking for Alaska I had lots of titles
misremembering Alaska the great perhaps
for a long time I wanted to call it warm
malt liquor a novel I was sorted as a
Hufflepuff in Pottermore can you console
me
couldn't sole you that you're joining
the house of hell the Hufflepuff and
tongs I'm not gonna console you all
congratulate you did you ever own a
diary yeah I maintain one periodically
from 1984 to 1988 it contains such
memorable entries as today was a good
day my brother got sick Hank I'll see
you on Monday